wait let's go back on we'll just kick it
on the back we'll just take that on the
back
what no honestly no no okay go ahead
start and come again wait wait
okay keep it rolling this will be like
after this is after you say you know
this is you know it's over keeps calling
me can i hold on i have to but you said
this you're not on the air now you know
it's over okay that's fine but marley's
calling me she she just called me like
three times that's why i was looking at
my phone okay
hey um so it's not fitting up the stairs
what are you talking about the nordic
track machine
he just like walked in and he was like
there's no way it's fitting up the
stairs
what's wrong with marley marley sounds
like she's did you just wake up sorry
we're on air with she had ambien
marley did you take an ambien
no i like honestly i like woke up at
like 5 a.m for no reason so then i
accidentally fell asleep
and i woke up in a panic because the
doorbell was ringing and i didn't know
what was going on and now this machine
won't go up the stairs
yeah so
what a great storyteller she is so
should you wait actually you don't think
it will oh i i was like oh like oh
no
i feel like it will i think i love that
she fills you in with her side of the
story i was like
don't you think it'll i feel like it
definitely will fit up there like that's
like such a normal
i don't know i was like yeah upstairs
and he was like there's just no way
i don't understand like it's just stupid
and then he also said it wouldn't fit in
the room
it will fit in the room like i know it
will fit in there well that's cause
there's like stuff everywhere i can move
it but i don't know
and then he just like left wait he left
well no he's like i'll be right back and
i was like oh and i was like hello and
then
i can't find it
wait do you think i should um just have
it i'm just going to have it taken to my
mom so i'll text you yeah do you have
their number maybe no oh my oh wait hold
on i'm going to message them on the app
well
i'm like pissed because i feel like a
nordictrack machine's nice and i wish we
headed at our pounds oh he's right here
do you want to talk to him yeah yeah
okay
hey hello hello
hi um so you don't think the machine
will fit up the stairs at all
no it won't at all yeah okay did i talk
like a commercial one
oh you got it
it's really white it's really wide
hi this is uh this is her dad talking
so you're saying it won't go through the
gate and then and then it won't even if
you got it through the gate it won't go
up the stairs and then if you if it got
up the stairs it won't fit in the room
absolutely okay so it won't go through
the gate it won't go through the up the
stairs and it doesn't fit in the room
could you set it up
on the street but it do have an extra
cord that i could plug it into the
neighbor's house and and put it in the
street i don't want to put it to the
side because i don't want to i don't
want the parking spaces to be taken so i
need it in the center lane so cars can
go by while i'm working out
pardon me
yeah we absolutely can do you want it
outside the street yeah but it's center
and and facing into traffic so i can see
if there's cars coming toward my
daughter
while she's working out
all right all right
okay i need an extension cord i want the
extension cord to go to the houses on
the west on the west side
okay but just set it up and get it
operating in the road
all right
pardon me i don't have any extension all
right thank you do what you can i hung
up
my god
that was beautiful was that on the
podcast
okay now they're not answering
what if he actually sets it up on the
street then gotta send us a picture okay
now there's motion at the front door
like they're genuinely gonna do that
can't get it through the gate he can't
get enough stairs it's not even one
problem it's everything
oh my gosh
hi um can i speak can i speak with that
can i speak with him
again sorry